it's like some ETA trophies you know I
mean like just all working like little
little gifts to yourself for the work
you didn't put in then I mean so that's
how I look at jewelry like little
trophies yo yo you already know it
should boy Davies and you are watching
on the rocks there's a rolling soup's on
giant big face Scott 100 is just rolling
60 follow the product protect Patti hi
view said Philippe this was the first
one I went got once I got my rap money
I'm saying so this one me and dear to me
Donna I got to protect from Raffaello in
New York City and this is from my god
Mazel Mazel yo I got a plane a plane jam
Gold's not brand management products but
my dad's on me for it I think you want I
think my dad trying to take it right now
I gotta figure that one out here on my
body
nice and long got my daughter go tennis
set earrings I got my mom's arobie when
I first time I deal knives gave me a
Scott brother I rock that for maybe like
two years and then my dad my dad got
that like he's like I watched
he's more than watches than me like I
got into watches once I got you know me
but he old my dad always had a nice
watch all my life so it was kind of my
gift to him
yeah they got George for a few people a
few people want me to get him jewelry I
ain't got it yet but a few people he got
Jade for inner strength in the Cuba this
one it's 300 the big one the smaller one
is about 21st saying I got was a gold
feeling this is gold
Cuban me I lost it and I lay in the
hotel I thought about it once I got to
the hip when I was like oh my God he's
my sweaters this one got my daughter
initials in it case he'd be this is got
the gold background this one is more to
taunt and go this one master watch it's
just like the same I got this ring when
I got my watch so this ring like is near
and dear to me and I didn't lost him at
times and it came back to me through the
graces of the universe so I like this
room
I don't believe in luck
so nah no cuz I feel like if it's a good
luck charm it's old I feel like it is a
good luck charm I'm a loser
[Music]
I loved all biggie that Jesus piece with
the Cuban but I feel like a bunch of
them did that in the 90s like mace had
that same pun knives of course that QB
piece was always insane to me
Raekwon great great go summary I mean al
Jovi ghost is definitely top five
all-time jewelry goes got crazy Jewish
jury is insane all the pieces with the
bird and all that to me it was it was
one of the dopest moments just cuz I
always looked up the knife and I mean
always was a fan his music so when I got
the call and then when I did audition I
got the role it was kind of surreal for
me because I idolized this dude then and
growing up it was a challenge but it was
also something that I had to kill it and
I mean just to be able to portray
somebody that's been that dope and that
influential saw culture for so long
preparation I own a guy with knife you
know I was doing to Staten Island
chopped it up with him and vibe with him
went over the script with him and
YouTube YouTube is like the best I was
able to go watch all the old
performances see how his mannerisms and
his Cadis and all of that it helped a
lot with just me playing his role
it's another cuter it matches my
bracelet
my daughter initials this is the first
avenue piece that on a Vianney made for
me just to block my grandmother had our
family and I mean he was over there in
Harlem this is kind of like a memory of
her and just my neighborhood her side
this right here is a custom piece my
label from the dirt so I flipped like
the NFL logo and I mean I put the FTD my
godmother did that for me some song
master bracelet in the wash there's a
lion hey you know I feel like I've been
in a jungle so long you know
just hold the joint right here was like
30 this Cuban was 40 oh I forgot this
piece up and why I see my man slow
actually Gators to me Fat Joe has a
store uptown New York call up NYC in
this day logo and I've been a big
supporter of his store since he opened
so I was like a gift from them
[Music]
yeah I want to do a bunch of these this
is my label so I'm gonna like do
different sizes do rings these might be
the ones I could give people and I mean
I feel like it could be a lot of times
just like relationships people have I'm
still waiting on fab you give me my
family piece but you know I'm saying
certain people that just got their own
logo or they own thing and you cool it
then you want to support it you know
survival it's a documentary to my life
intro to outro speaking on things I
never really spoke on before and I mean
if I could really put my life up into
this point in words that survival
[Music]